Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Test geht.
Ja, ich bin gerade so richtig an den Rechner und habe jetzt schon mal angemacht,
habe mir noch was zu essen geholt, habe ich gerade mitgebracht.
Das heißt, ich muss gleich wieder was futtern.
Ich kann schon mal meine VM anmachen.
Was war denn hier mal?
Was war hier?
Irgendwas, was ich letzter Zeit aninstallt habe.
Was zu essen?
Es gibt ein Brötchen, ein Toastbrot und ein bisschen Abel, wie der Hesse so sagt.
Ich kack Noob
Kack Wade, Alter
Das ist die falsche Pro-Am gewesen
Ich hab mir schon gedacht, was macht die für Dinger
Und warum sieht die so komisch aus
Zu viel Pro-Ams am Start
Ja, das sieht doch schon viel mehr nach dem aus
Moin
Ah ja
Ich bin
Heute
Warte mal
Ich hab gedacht wenn man auf die Uhr klickt kommt ne Uhr
Wir sind ja unter Windows hab ich vergessen
Da passiert ja eigentlich nix intuitives
Ich bin so bis 20 Uhr 30 oder so
Wahrscheinlich da.
Danach gucke ich noch ein bisschen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ein bisschen Fernsehserie oder irgendwas.
Oder.
Man weiß noch nicht.
Champions League danach.
Nee, Fußball gucke ich nicht.
Fußball ist gar nicht meins.
Ich habe nicht übermäßig viel, glaube ich,
von meinem Opa
geerbt, kann man nicht sagen.
Wie nennt man das?
Geerbt, heißt das glaube ich auch.
Geht ja nicht immer nur ums Geld.
Ich habe nicht übermäßig viel von meinem Opa geerbt,
aber, dass ich
Fußball nicht mag, das habe ich vom Opa.
Der mochte Fußball auch nicht.
Hast du Severance fertig?
Ja. Doofes Ende, oder?
Wie findest du Kotlin?
Ich habe in Kotlin... Moment!
Moment.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich habe in Kotlin
noch nie was gemacht.
Das stimmt nicht so ganz, gell?
Ich glaube, wir haben mal ganz
kurz uns das angeguckt.
Ganz kurz.
Weiß ich noch. So ein Stream lang oder so.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Guck mal.
Wir haben einen Stream gemacht
Vor zwei Jahren
Wo wir uns drei Stunden
Kotlin angeguckt haben
Und ich glaube ich fand es gar nicht so schlecht
Also man merkt sich ja negative Sachen
Immer mehr
Das heißt hätte ich das wirklich
Schlecht gefunden
Dann hätte ich es mir wahrscheinlich gemerkt
Und nachdem ich es nicht mehr weiß
Kann es nicht so schlecht gewesen sein
Da erinnere ich mich nur noch dunkel dran
Das war das, wo sie den hinter der Tür eingesperrt haben, gell?
Den Aufpasser
Ja, also wahrscheinlich fand ich Kotlin ganz gut
Wie findest du Kotlin?
Ich habe nicht so viele Anwendungszwecke dafür, weil ich eigentlich nichts auf Java-Basis oder JVM muss man ja eigentlich sagen, ja.
Basis mache.
So, machen wir mal kurz. Oh, guck mal hier.
Der Hintergrund meint schon, wir haben nicht mehr Nachmittag, wir haben schon Abend.
Wie wichtig findest du frisch nach der Ausbildung zum Physi-Zertifikate, also CCNA?
Ich finde Zertifikate allgemein ziemlich unsinnig.
kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an gibt welche die legen da wert drauf aber dass
die meisten die von zertifikaten profitieren sind die zertifikate
anbieter dieses ganze zertifikate ökosystem das sondern sich sich selbst
erhalten der kreislauf an set hersteller zertifizierung trainings trainer
zertifizierung trainings und letztendlich ist das eigentlich ein
bisschen so die lizenz zum geld drucken als zertifikate ob es wirklich viel
bringt ich habe da meine zweifel gibt die ein oder anderen arbeitgeber die
stehen da voll drauf aber ich habe es bisher noch nicht erlebt dass das heißt
nicht dass es das nicht gibt ja aber ich habe so nicht erlebt dass ich habe so
nicht noch nicht mitbekommen dass es irgendwo mal hieße order typ der ist ja
ganz gut aber dem fiel dieses eine zertifikat was wir unbedingt haben
wollen deswegen nehmen wir ihn nicht das habe ich noch nicht erlebt wie gesagt
nicht dass das nicht gibt aber ich habe es noch nirgendwo erlebt oder gehört
also ich kenne keine arbeitgeber die wenn du einen qualifizierten eindruck
machst oder einen guten eindruck gemacht hast jetzt irgendwie super wert darauf
würden dass du jetzt da sein ordner mit zertifikaten aufmacht
das ist ich kenne mich mit java so weniger so wenig aus dass ich keine
ahnung habe was setter und getter methoden für attribute sind ich kann mir
das im dotnet c sharp kontext vorstellen da weiß ich was getter und setter sind
weiß ich was attribute sind da wahrscheinlich ist das bei japan das
was anderes
also ich habe bei mir in den lebenslauf erst gar nicht rein geschrieben dass ich
ein cc na hab who cares wenn juck dass ich mal ccn a gemacht habe
vor zig Jahren.
Und
dafür habe ich GitHub-Projekte reingeschrieben.
Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich,
dass der
Fiat Champ in meiner Bewerbung drin stand?
Jetzt ist er drei Jahre outdated,
overrated, jebaited.
Fehler.
Müssen ja alles
anwender fehler sein weil das wir programmieren ja immer fehlerfrei
richtig sag ich doch so ist es so ist es
du kannst nur fürs testen sprechen aber ohne ist qbc ich habe keine ahnung was
das ist was ist die sd ist ach du scheiß kremer ist qb international software testing qualification
board software testing warum muss man da braucht man ein zertifikat für ich meine die besten tests
sind natürlich sachen wenn man immer fehlerfrei programmiert weil dann brauchst du keine
dokumentation keine kommandant aber ich meine ich habe kein zertifikaten habe es auch geschafft
tests zu erstellen warum brauchen wir da warum ist das so wichtig ist das ist das wichtig weil
wirklich inhaltlich was bei rum kommt oder ist das so wichtig weil da viele arbeitgeber drauf
stehen nein mache ich jetzt moment in welchem channel ich gucke mir das jetzt an weil ich
habe das letzte mal schon gesagt ich gucke es mir und habe es mir nicht angeguckt ich gucke
mir jetzt an moment moment ich gehe jetzt bei mir auf dem discord in welchem channel muss ich
cute chat
eier
moment auch der ist niedlich der guckt ein bisschen geschockt
was fotografierst du mich
rote katzen sind
18 oder noch mehr ok moment moment habe schon wieder zugemacht keck wait
hier die weiße und dies auch niedlich muss aufpassen dass er den fußball ist
der tschecho hat sich gerne bei mir am fuß festgehalten da muss ich immer
aufpassen also ohne socken konnte ständig in ja und das kicken das kicken hat die auch
immer gemacht ich kann euch jetzt das video nicht zeigen leute gerade weil ich so auf
auf dem Handy auf habe und ich nicht eingeloggt bin hier im Discord.
Aber ich habe dem RFProgrammer das letzte Mal
schon versprochen, ich gucke sein Katzenvideo an.
Da muss ich das jetzt ja auch mal
irgendwann machen.
Ja, niedlich.
Sieht auch klein aus, oder?
Es gibt keine Bugs, wenn es keinen Bugtracker gibt.
Richtig.
Wow.
Was beim Katzen Zahnarzt
Es gibt ja mittlerweile als was wahrscheinlich beim Tierarzt sie waren es aber es gibt mittlerweile
Augenärzte für Katzen wusste ihr das
Ich war ja mit Chico mal bei einem
Es gibt wirklich welche die haben sich auch so was spezialisiert es glaubt man gar nicht also da hat sich da die letzten Jahre ist enorm viel
passiert in der Richtung
Ja, ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich war jetzt aber schon gestern und...
...Weitere oder irgendwann?
Augen sind Baustellen.
Nö, nicht wirklich.
Ich war mit Chico beim Katzenaugenarzt, weil die hatte zu hohen Blutdruck.
Nicht, weil sie zu dick war.
die hatte zu hohen Blutdruck.
Und da war ich beim Augenarzt.
Weil ich hab einmal gesehen, dass die
die hatte so ein bisschen
rot in den Augen. Da hab ich gedacht, ist das Blut?
Oder was ist das?
Und das war ein größerer Akt, bei Chico Blutdruck zu messen.
Katzen kriegen am Schwanz Blutdruck gemessen.
Und
dann war ich beim Augenarzt mit Chico.
So, jetzt haben wir hier alles geupdatet.
Oder? Gibt es noch mehr?
Macht das Jetbrains Zeug?
About.
Äh.
By the way,
warum muss ich mich hier eigentlich nicht einloggen
bei Jetbrains und kann trotzdem alles machen?
Auf meinem anderen, auf meiner anderen VM muss ich immer eingeloggt sein, dass es funktioniert.
Komisch.
Das muss ich jetzt nicht verstehen, oder?
Hast du den Nightbot programmiert? Was, wie, hä?
Das geht glaube ich bei allen.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern,
dass wir das mal eingerichtet haben.
So.
Reboot.
Wisst ihr?
Geht überall.
Und Chat, wie war heute euer Daily Scrum?
Habt ihr schön gestand-
Stand-upped.
Ich hatte heute Sprint-Review,
Sprint-Retrospektive und
Sprint-Planning.
Alles in einem hier.
Da ging's ab. Hyper-Agile.
Wurde da gesprintet.
Ja.
Das war so agile.
er ist das morgen wo ich in welchem intervall in welchem intervall wird bei
euch gesprintet als bei uns alle 14 tage
zwei war bei euch auch zwei wochen okay
npm ja ich noch was neues jetzt habe ich was verpasst das letzte was ich
mitgekriegt habe war wo die den maintainer gefischt haben von cli
packages zum größten teil cli packages der wäre richtig stolz ja jetzt wieder
was neues bei npm registry probleme wenn man es mal so will kommt kommt ja
bestimmt alle halbe jahr mal irgendwas vor
ach ja wieder wirklich da weiß jetzt gar nicht was du meinst das ist bestimmt
irgendwas was ich nur umschrieben habe und ich wirklich so heiß weil ich
anonymisiert ja manchmal sachen
16, ach ja,
self-replicating
warm hits, 180 plus
npm package to steal credentials
okay, die haben es
richtig gemacht,
also richtig, richtig in Anführungszeichen
Die haben die Pakete mit Post-Install-Skripts wahrscheinlich jetzt getargetet.
Hat doch jemand...
Keine Ahnung, da weiß ich gerade nicht mehr, was du meinst.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen drüber nachfälle, fällt es mir wieder ein,
sag ich, ach ja, klar, das...
Cyber Security Reset Reflect,
Fresh Software Supply,
NPM Registry, 40 Pakete sind
GoLang Template, Moment, Moment,
warum gibt es ein Paket, das sich
GoLang Template nennt,
als JavaScript?
Schließt sich das
nicht rein von der Logik
her aus?
Ach das meinst du
Jetzt weiß ich wieder
Was ist das hier
Warum kackt der Player ab
Bestimmt wieder Youtube Werbung
Ja, eindeutig YouTube-Werke.
Hier irgendwo waren wir.
Jetzt weiß ich auch wieder,
was du meinst mit diesem Everything-Projekt.
Der Typ, der einen
NPM-Package erstellt hat,
das Dependency hatte auf alle anderen
NPM-Packages.
Das meinst du, gell?
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Ich dachte, du meinst was, was ich irgendwann mal von der Arbeit
erzählt habe.
Da erzähle ich ja auch viele Sachen, aber ich anonymisiere das immer so ein bisschen.
Ist da irgendwelche großen Projekte dabei?
Aber das ist ja mal durch die Bank weg hier.
Jetzt alles Angular Zeug, Native Script.
Okay, dann fängt man sich irgendwelche
Irgendwelche, ähm
Tja, wie kann man sagen
Ist das nicht wirklich ein Keylogger
Da fängt man sich irgendwelche Malware ein
Das dann das System nach Secrets scannt
Das ist deutlich schlimmer als das letzte
Beim letzten haben sie ja in Anführungsstrichen nur kleinzeitig was eingebaut
Und wenn du das auf den falschen Seiten quasi live genommen hättest
Wenn du irgendeine Kryptoseite hast, dann hätten sie da Sachen überweisen können
Das hier ist jetzt deutlich schlimmer sogar
ja
more packages impact ist ja gar nicht mehr auf
leute der vier champ ist safe
ember verwendet wirklich noch jemand ember
ember war eines der ersten so kleines
seit javascript dinger war frame park
Viel Spaß.
Ich kenne mich im JavaScript-Umfeld zu wenig aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da große Pakete dabei sind.
Aber NPM kommt nicht zur Ruhe hier, hä?
Und Crates.io, ist das nicht Rust?
Wenn auch gefischt alle werden gefischt habe auch schon zig zig hunderte fishing mails gekriegt und alles mögliche
Aus token in plane der wie willst du denn ein wein und variablen anders setzen als als plaintext
Oh ne.
Leute, ich bin
hier eingeloggt.
Moment, wann?
So.
Irgendwelche komischen
Werbungsgedöns brauchen wir nicht.
Ja, Leute, ich muss jetzt mal was essen.
Also ich gehe nicht off.
Ich habe mir jetzt hier extra hier nebenhin gestellt.
Lasst uns mal gucken, ob wir uns irgendwas nebenbei auf YouTube anschauen können.
Dass ich euch nicht so ins Ohr voll schmatze.
Übelst Hunger.
Stimmt, jetzt wo ich das gerade hier sehe.
Was machen eigentlich meine Stonks?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Scalable Stonks.
Die sagen, dass...
Ach, ist wieder ein bisschen hochgegangen. Okay.
Scalable schickt wieder erstmal drei Popups am Anfang.
Barcode-Verschwörung.
Nee, ich brauche jetzt irgendwas, das den Kopf abschalten kann, weil...
Stonks sind gefallen und jetzt wieder gestiegen. Das ist nice.
Und heute sind sie nochmal gefallen. Super.
Aber Stonks sind immer noch richtig hart im Plus.
So muss das sein.
Was haben wir denn hier? Was können wir uns denn angucken?
Ich habe mein Homelab komplett überarbeitet.
ausgaben ach nee wir wollen uns doch gestern dass da bin ich da bin ich
garantiert wieder jeder welt bin da bin ich wieder geträgert wenn ich mir
fahrrad infrastruktur in deutschland angucke lieber nicht lieber dich mal
first server ist heini ok das kann ich mal kurz durch ob der irgendwo ist das
was 3d gedrucktes
Ich kann jetzt schwer den Formfaktor einschätzen, weil ich nichts im Vergleich sehe.
Ach hier, das ist so eine Mauspad.
Das ist nicht 19 Zoll, oder?
Das ist irgendwie 8 Zoll.
Was ist das für ein Formfaktor?
10 Zoll.
Das gibt es für so Netzwerkgeräte, so kleine, kleinen Netzwerk-Kram, ne?
Es sieht ja schon fast niedlich aus.
PewDiePie-Video, na ne, das halt schnell aus.
Auch wenn er jetzt ein Arch-Linux-By-The-Way-User ist.
Dieses Ding ist voll beliebt bei vielen Leuten auf YouTube, ich weiß nicht was.
dieses Seamer Board, kein Schimmer.
Okay, wie sieht es aus, wenn es fertig ist?
Raspberry Pi hin.
Okay, so ein Display da dran braucht kein Mensch.
So ein Display,
der einzige sinnvolle Anwendungszweck für ein Display
ist, dass man damit angeben kann,
wie cool sein Rack aussieht.
So.
Moment, hat er da sogar Wechsel-
Festplatten-Discs drinne?
Ne.
Fuck.
Ja.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn ich mir
ein Rack daheim hinstelle,
dann 19 Zoll,
da kann ich wenigstens alles einbauen, was ich will.
Weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, aber
ich finde, alles drunter
ist irgendwie nicht
nicht sinnig.
LED?
Ja gut, LED ist für die Performance wichtig.
Wenn du angeben willst,
gehst du doch auch eher auf
Ubiquiti, oder? Naja.
Ja, vielleicht,
wenn man gerne irgendwelche
Videos macht und
man nennt sich über sein
Unify
Netzwerk auslässt und dann
Wie hieß der eine
Der immer
Die Videos zeigt mein Homelab
Und dann hat er irgendwie zwei Kubernetes Cluster
Daheim und zig
Hundert Sachen die sich eigentlich nur selbst verwalten
Das ist eh der beste
Techno Tim
Der hat im Prinzip
Sein ganzes Zeug nur um sich selbst zu verwalten
Der hat so gut wie nix
Wirklich an Anwendung laufen
Was haben wir denn hier?
Er hat sein Homelab überarbeitet
Das klingt doch schon mal gar nicht so schlecht
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht
New CSS Features
Das gucken wir heute im Laufe des Tages noch an
Weil ich will
Ein bisschen auf dem aktuellen Stand bleiben
Was Frontend Sachen angeht
Das Frontend-Game muss ja up-to-date bleiben.
Huch, warum ist das neu?
Achso, manchmal bin ich auch echt braindead, oder?
Ich habe gerade ernsthaft mir gedacht, warum hat sich das neu gestartet?
Ja, warum wohl? Weil ich Reboot eingegeben habe vor 10 Minuten.
Warum Chromium statt Firefox?
Ich habe auch noch Firefox.
Ich habe Firefox, Chromium und Chrome.
Ich habe alles am Start.
Na gut, alles nicht.
Es gibt ja noch ein paar andere.
Na gut, streng genommen war es das eigentlich. Es gibt ja eigentlich nur noch zwei Browser, wenn man so will.
Egal was es ist, es ist entweder Edge... Quatsch.
Es ist entweder Chromium basiert oder es ist Firefox.
Ja, es gibt Safari, aber ganz ehrlich...
Safari muss man nicht beachten.
Das sage ich als iPhone-User.
Internet Explorer, den gibt es nicht mehr.
Ja, Safari muss man nicht beachten.
Safari ist der neue Internet Explorer.
Der Brave Vivaldi in Opera sind alle drei Chromium-based.
Der alte Opera, nicht.
Der ganz alte Opera war nicht Chromium-based.
Aber das war ja schon 10 Jahre her.
Kann man den eh nicht noch bei Features nachladen?
Doch, doch.
Kann den Kram sogar noch...
Ich glaube, der ist sogar standardmäßig.
Ne, ist nicht mehr drauf.
Den kannst du noch nachinstallieren.
Den gibt es auch noch.
Aber das ist mittlerweile eigentlich nicht notwendig.
Die einzige Daseinsberechtigung, die Internet Explorer noch hat, ist, falls du irgendeine uralte Business Enterprise Legacy Anwendung hast,
die nur gescheit mit Internet Explorer oder irgendwelche...
Wie hieß der Krempel beim Internet Explorer?
Active X, oder?
ja genau activex activex und wisst ihr was die auch noch hatten beim internet explorer die hatten
noch silver light erinnert sich noch irgendjemand als silver light er hat schießt silver light
dachte ich auch gerade dran
Flash
Flash war ja
das lief ja überall
aber ActiveX und Silverlight
lief glaube ich nur, wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin
ob es nicht auch ein Silverlight Plugin für Firefox und so gab
aber auf jeden Fall am besten
im Internet Explorer
Lohnt sich noch
Programmieren zu lernen an sich der
rasanten Entwicklung von natürlich
das lohnt sich
mehr denn je
also ich gehe nicht davon aus
dass Programmierer jemals
durch AI ersetzt werden
könnt mir vorstellen, dass das in immer mehr Workflows
einfließt, ja
und gerade für, sagen wir mal
komplette Noobs
bevor die kein Plan was haben
haben sie wenigstens
ein bisschen Plan mit Autogenerierung
letztendlich, letztendlich
AI ist ja so eine Art Code Completion
wenn man es so will, eine sehr umfangreiche Code Completion
haben die
ein bisschen mehr Zeug, was sie machen können.
Wichtig ist aber halt, dass sie dann das auch als Anlass nehmen,
um zu verstehen, was da eigentlich läuft.
Ich glaube, wir werden, das sieht man ja jetzt schon,
teilweise überschwemmt von sinnlosen AI-Code.
Und was ich auch ganz ätzend finde,
sind Pull-Requests per AI generiert.
Ich mag das überhaupt nicht.
Weil bei einem Pull-Request geht es ja nicht unbedingt darum,
möglichst blumig und schön zu umschreiben, was in dem Change passiert,
sondern die wichtigen Sachen zu highlighten und vor allem mit dem Hintergedanken dahinter,
warum man das gemacht hat.
Das ist ja oftmals das Interessante, warum man das gemacht hat.
Und das ist halt schwierig für die AI.
Die AI weiß nicht, was du dir gedacht hast zu dem Zeitpunkt, als du dir überlegt hast,
ach, das wäre eine gute Änderung.
Ja, vielleicht, was du machen kannst, ist so ein Standard-Pull-Request des Fixes Issue 5798.
Okay.
Aber ansonsten sieht man gerade auf, also wie soll ich es nennen, so was Technik-Literatur angeht, nennen wir es mal so, Blogs oder auch autogenerierte Videos und sowas.
Da gibt es seit 1-2 Jahren, sagen wir mal seit 2 Jahren, eine so übertriebene AI-Schwelle.
Wer hatte das nicht schon, dass ihr bei Google was gesucht habt, ihr findet einen Artikel und denkt sich, ey, klingt doch erstmal ganz gut.
Dann fangt ihr an zu lesen und nach dem zweiten Satz denkt ihr euch, scheiße, gleich wieder zu.
Weil einfach nur AI generiert.
Und die gibt es wirklich zu 100.000 mittlerweile, diese Artikel.
Und noch schlimmer sind die Bots, die diese Artikel dann auf Reddit posten.
Also siehst du teilweise auf Reddit irgendwie, oh hier, toller neuer Blogpost zum Thema XY.
Und denkst dir schon so, wenn du das liest, so, hm.
Ich habe den Verdacht, das ist ein Bot, der da gepostet hat.
Klickst doch drauf und das erste, was siehst, BAM, AI generiert.
Das ist halt wirklich nervig.
Also diese AI-Content-Schwämme ist ätzend.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, was Kreativecke mit seinem Homelab macht.
Ich liebe IT. Also kein Spaß.
Ich auch.
Ich liebe Informationstechnologie.
Aber das sollte jedem klar sein, denn sonst hätte ich diesen YouTube-Channel nicht.
Und seit meiner Kindheit bin ich von einer Sache fasziniert.
Nämlich, wenn zwei oder mehrere Computer miteinander kommunizieren.
Und eigentlich habe ich mir über die Jahre eine Netzwerkstruktur aufgebaut, die ich leider etwas habe verkommen lassen.
Da bleibt nur Talkering, Leute.
So, ich esse jetzt mal was.
Das hat mich aber dazu gebracht, das Ganze neu anzugehen, weshalb ich euch heute den Zwischenstand meines Homelabs präsentieren will.
Da bin ich aber gespannt.
Wenn ihr aktuell in der Situation seid, dass ihr euer Case mit Kabelbindern zusammensetzt,
Ah, erstmal Placement. Aber egal.
Leute, gucken wir uns das Placement an.
Wenn ihr die Sonne halten müsst, wird es vielleicht Zeit für ein Upgrade.
Was gibt's? Nix Tolles. Ein Brötchen, ein Toastbrot und ein Appel.
Auf dem Brötchen ist Salami und Käse drauf.
Auf dem Toastbrot ist so eine Art Marmelade drauf.
Und der gute Appel ist ein Appel.
Passend dafür hat Corsair zusammen mit Alternate gerade eine Aktion am Start.
Unter dem Motto Local Heroes Powered by Corsair gibt es momentan schöne Rabatte auf alle Corsair-Parts aus dem DIY-Bereich.
Bis zu 14% auf Wasserkühlungen, bis zu 26% auf Lüfter, bis zu 16% auf Netzteile und noch viel, viel mehr gibt es bei dieser Aktion.
Und apropos Netzteile, passend dazu hat Corsair noch einen Advanced RMA-Service auf Netzteile.
Arbeitest du noch bei einer Bank? Ne.
Ja, aber manchmal bei einer Versicherung.
Jetzt Teile in Deutschland gelauncht, also wenn ihr ein Upgrade braucht, dann schaut nach dem Video auf jeden Fall mal bei Alternate vorbei.
Okay, für den Kontext...
Aber Alternate ist wirklich gut.
Ist unabhängig von dem Placement, ob man das braucht, was auch immer, aber...
Alternate kann man echt bestellen.
Bestellen seit Jahren immer wieder, bei Alternate hat man nie Probleme.
Und das eine Mal, wo ich Probleme hatte, da hab ich's verkackt, da hab ich die falsche Adresse angegeben, haben die auch easy geregelt.
haben einfach gesagt, ey, bestell neu mit der richtigen Adresse.
Sobald das alte zurückkommt, dann stornieren wir.
Es hat auch alles ohne Probleme funktioniert.
Das ist erstmal die Story.
Ich bin letztens aus dem Urlaub gekommen, betrete mein YouTube-Studio.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich ein separates Studio hierfür.
Und denke mir, du könntest mal wieder aufräumen und entstauben.
Ja, das habe ich vor dem Urlaub nicht gemacht.
Tja, bis ich dann mal hinter meine Netzwerkzentrale schaute und gesehen habe,
dass die Steckdose, an der wirklich alles dran ist,
da raushängt.
Also wirklich aus der Wand raus.
Naja, da passiert erst einmal nichts.
Aber...
Gut ist es natürlich auf Dauer nicht.
Vor allem nicht,
wenn du da mal ordentlich dran ziehen willst.
Und weil das Kabelmanagement
die Vollkatastrophe schlechthin war,
ja, Leute, das ist die ungeschönte Realität.
Keine Hochglanzaufnahmen,
keine Filter.
Da gibt es aber echt Schlimmeres.
So sah das früher bei mir auch aus.
Und das lief jahrelang.
Ich bin eine Sau, ich weiß.
Ich meine, ich habe mir ja nicht mal markiert, welches Netzwerkkabel wo dran hängt.
Da dachte ich mir, es wird Zeit für eine Grundsanierung.
Und da ich schon mal dabei war, nicht nur eine Grundsanierung in Bezug auf die physisch vorhandene Technik meines Homelabs,
sondern vor allem auch in Bezug auf meine Softwarelösungen.
Und ich hoste mittlerweile meinen eigenen Netzwerkspeicher, meine eigene Cloud,
die all meine Daten auf allen Geräten synchronisiert und nur limitiert ist durch den Speicher bei mir zu Hause,
den ich jederzeit erweitern kann.
Mein eigenes papierloses Büro, meine eigenen persönlichen Daten...
Gab es bei Synology nicht letztens die News, dass sie nur noch irgendwie abgesegnete Festplatten akzeptieren wollen?
Also allein schon deswegen wäre Synology bei mir unten durch.
Meine eigene Passwortmanager.
Ja, ich hoste sogar meine eigene KI.
Und es soll noch viel mehr dazu kommen.
Aber für alle, die mit dem Begriff nichts anfangen können, was ist eigentlich ein Homelab?
Wenn man es definieren müsste, wäre das Homelab ein privates Test- und Produktionsnetzwerk,
in dem man eigene Serverdienste betreibt, Dinge ausprobiert und sich Systeme so baut,
ob jetzt hardware-technisch oder software-technisch, wie man das selbst möchte.
Und das ohne Unsicherheiten und Einschränkungen von irgendwelchen Drittanbietern.
Das Ding sieht aus wie irgendwie so ein Tarnbomber.
Und damit ihr euch einen Überblick machen könnt,
also nicht mit den Antennen, aber von der Form,
wie das aktuell bei mir aussieht,
schauen wir einfach mal so eine reale Aufnahme aus meinem Studio.
Ja, und hier sind wir an meiner Serverzentrale,
beziehungsweise meiner Homelab-Zentrale.
Das ist super unkonventionell.
Ich glaube, das macht in der Form auch fast niemand.
Ich habe nämlich keinen Netzwerkschrank.
Das liegt aber daran, dass mein Studio ein einziger Raum ist.
Und wenn ich jetzt einen Netzwerkschrank mit zusätzlichen Lüftern hätte und so...
Man braucht ja für zwei, drei Geräte...
...kannst du kein extra Rack oder sonst was.
Zumal die Dinger eh nicht Rack-Mountable sind.
90% der Leute haben wahrscheinlich ihre Router und Fritzboxen einfach so irgendwo draufstehen.
Oder wenn sich die Frau beschwert, irgendwo hinterm Schrank hängen.
gibt ja welche, die sagen, oh nein, sobald man Technik sieht, ist das ganz Wohnung verschandelt.
Dann wäre das ultra laut.
Stattdessen habe ich die Geräte hier freistehen.
Die kriegen immer frische Luft.
Das heißt, das ist nicht problematisch.
Sie sind auch nicht zu laut.
Ja, wenn du WLAN-Sachen in Slack stellst, ist es in der Regel nicht gut.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn du beispielsweise einen Sensor an deinen Briefkasten machen willst
und machst den Sensor
in den, du willst quasi
Wireless, willst du irgendwie
rauskommen aus dem metallenen Briefkasten.
Das ist auch
schwierig.
Ich habe das mit so einem Zigbee Kontakt
probiert. Es hat nicht richtig
gut funktioniert.
Zwischenzeitlich hatte ich es anders gemacht.
Da habe ich versucht quasi
Kontakt dran zu machen und dann außen was
dran, aber mittlerweile ist mein
Briefkasten nicht mehr smart.
Guck einfach einmal am Tag rein.
Routine schlägt
Smart Home. Einfach, wenn ich
aus der Tür rausgehe,
einfach mal nachmittags reingucken, fertig.
Mach ich so oder so?
Der muss nicht smart sein.
Ich hab die Lüfter von dem Synology NAS
entsprechend ein bisschen runter geregelt
und ja, das ist wohl die Zentrale,
also mein Router, der GT-AXE16000, das ist ein total wilder Router von Asus, hat auch 10 Gigabit
Ethernet. Mein Hauptsystem ist auch mit 10 Gigabit Ethernet angebunden. Nur, ja, ich sag mal, das
Problem ist, das ist ein Router ohne Modem. Deshalb seht ihr noch dieses kleine Gerät da drauf, das
Vigor 160 von DrayTag. Das ist einfach nur ein Modem, das wir ins Internet kommen. Und ja, hier,
das ist wohl so ziemlich die speicherzentrale schlechthin ist das ein 10 gig switch da oben
drauf könnte sein
weil ich habe mal gelesen vor einer weile irgendwelche news dass es jetzt ein 10 gig
switch von asus gibt ist er das man also sind wirklich die bekannte switch hersteller
das ist das synology ds 18 23 xs plus das habe ich euch vor ungefähr zwei jahren schon mal
vorgestellt als ich hier angefangen habe mit so ein bisschen ich hatte auch noch nie einen asus
switch umlebing sage ich mal und ich dachte oder wie man charakterweise sagen müsste asus ich wäre
zufrieden damit. Bis ich dann festgestellt
habe, Netzwerkspeicher, schön und
gut, alles darüber hinaus,
virtuelle Maschinen, irgendwelche anderen
Dienste, Vault Warden und
so weiter und so fort, ist
relativ schwierig darauf,
beziehungsweise läuft nicht immer so auf Anhieb
und ganz so Open Source, wie ich mir das wünschen würde,
ist es auch nicht. Weshalb, ich weiß
nicht, ob ihr das jetzt hier gut sehen könnt,
ich dahinter, äh, einmal
Kabelmanagement ignorieren an der Stelle.
Na komm,
das Zeug ist ordentlicher als bei den
meisten anderen das ist ja beschriftet bisschen zumindest zusammengebunden also kann man ja wo
kann man gar nichts sagen dagegen noch mal ist also so dass das store das gleiche als store
gehört zu asus raspberry pi habe das sind zwei drei und ein pfeff 5 der p5 der hat tatsächlich
auch eine aufgabe der übernimmt dann hier sehr sehr viele dienste in dem netzwerk wie zum beispiel
keine ahnung also unter anderem auch homer diese ganze übersicht ich habe und so weiter die drei
sind eher zum experimentieren weil ich aber so viele geräte habe wichtig bevor man irgendwas
hat leute braucht man ein schönes dashboard wenn das immer so lustig man sieht das auch auf reddit
da hast du gefühlt die hälfte der post behauptet sind oder smart home sind schaut euch mal neues
dashboard an
kann auch mal so eine dashboard lösung laufen benutze ich nicht mehr ich habe
alles soweit in home assistant integriert und kann das da über das frontend machen
musste ich natürlich noch ein netzwerk switch installieren und ich sage euch
ganz klar kauft euch nicht diesen netzwerk switch gekauft weil ich gelesen
habe 10 gigabit erzählt steht auch noch mehr drauf habe ich vorhin gar nicht
gelesen richtig 10g base t ist ja geil dann kann ich ja im prinzip alles über
den 10 gigabit ethernet an meinem router verbinden und habe dann quasi intern 10
gigabit netz funktioniert so nicht er hat nämlich nur zwei 10 gigabit ports
und ja die sind natürlich sofort voll das ist ein bisschen
das habe ich nicht verstanden
Du hast zwei 10 Gigabit Ports.
Und das andere sind was?
Eins oder 2,5?
Schade.
Da will ich auch nochmal upgraden.
Aber ich habe hier halt extrem viele Geräte dran.
Ich habe es aber nicht wirklich verstanden, ehrlich gesagt.
Also er dachte, das sind alles 10 Gig, aber ist es gar nicht, oder?
Das ist das Problem.
Oder habe ich es nicht kapiert?
Ich glaube, ich habe es nicht kapiert.
Unter anderem auch hier von Western Digital, die WD-MyCloud.
Die habe ich mir ganz ursprünglich geholt, als ich mal die Idee hatte zu sagen,
okay, ich richte mir so eine Art Homelab ein.
Das Ding da, das ist ein absoluter Fehler.
Das kann ich euch auch nicht empfehlen, weil das ist viel zu wenig offen.
Also ihr könnt da ganz, ganz wenig selbst dran machen.
Das ist...
Ja, und es sieht doof aus.
Im Prinzip wie so ein Cloud-Speicher im Netzwerk, in einer Dateiverwaltung.
Das kann sein, ja.
Mittlerweile könnt ihr auch Plex drauf installieren, aber das war es schon, obwohl das Ding relativ
leistungsstark ist.
Ja, und vorher sah das deutlich schlimmer aus.
Anlass war eigentlich diese Steckdose, weil die hing aus der Wand und dann habe ich gedacht,
naja, dann gehe ich da hin und installiere mal einen sicheren Mehrfachstecker von, äh,
Brennstuhl.
Und da hängt mittlerweile alles dran.
So, und das ist mein aktuelles völlig...
Wenn ich gerade keine Videos machen kann und ich auch wenig gestreamt habe in letzter Zeit.
Ungeschöntes Setup. Das sieht natürlich sehr unkonventionell aus.
Aber wie ich schon gesagt habe, mit einem Serverschrank und extra Lüftern, da wäre das im Raum einfach zu laut.
Und es geht ja primär auch darum, dass...
Schön gemacht mit dieser Kameras, mit dem Kamerasliden davor.
...es einfach funktioniert.
Und jetzt vielleicht kurz zum Aufbau des Netzwerks.
Ich bin auch Fan davon.
Man muss es nicht verüberkomplizieren.
Solange es das macht, was man will, ist gut.
Weil, man darf immer nicht vergessen,
wollte ich jetzt nochmal sagen,
nur weil man eine Sache hochverfügbar machen möchte,
heißt das nicht zwangsläufig, dass es am Ende mehr verfügbar ist.
Also das muss dann schon richtig gemacht sein,
denn Hochverfügbarkeit selber birgt ja auch ein zusätzliches Ausfallrisiko.
Nur weil man was hochverfügbar macht, heißt nicht automatisch,
dass es quasi so ist wie vorher, nur doppelt quasi.
Das fängt ja beispielsweise schon damit an,
dass du um eine
Hochverfügbarkeit, also um ordentlich
eine Hochverfügbarkeitslösung zu machen, sagen wir mal
du willst beispielsweise zwei Sachen
ähm, zweimal das
gleiche einfach laufen lassen, sodass eins übernehmen
kann, wenn das andere kaputt geht
dann musst du dir überlegen, okay
du kannst die Geräte eigentlich nicht
miteinander über das Netzwerk
kommunizieren lassen, sondern brauchst ein eigenes
Interconnect Kabel nochmal, das heißt
beide müssen ans Netzwerk
und ähm
Du musst die Geräte aber nochmal miteinander selbst verbinden, weil ansonsten würde jeder denken, dass der andere weg ist, wenn dein Switch kaputt geht.
Und dann muss man noch sagen, eigentlich kannst du Hochverfügbarkeit mit zwei Geräten gar nicht richtig machen.
Um das richtig auszulosen, wer denn dann machst, du brauchst eigentlich drei.
Genau.
Jetzt hat der Chat schon aufgepasst.
Der Chat sitzt schon da.
Der Max sagt zwei.
Das stimmt nicht.
Es sind drei.
Ich schreibe jetzt drei.
Mist, jetzt hat er gesagt 3. Ja, und eigentlich brauchst du 3. Und das macht es ziemlich komplex, was natürlich dann auch fehleranfälliger ist.
Und ich glaube, ich habe jetzt in den letzten, naja, ich mache das jetzt nicht ganz 20 Jahre, ich würde sagen, ich habe gefühlt mehr Ausfälle durch Hochverfügbarkeitslösungen gesehen, durch die Komplexität, die die reingebracht haben.
dass man doppelte IPs hatte
oder irgendwie sich anders
irgendwo anders vertan hat
das Probleme gab weil das Netzwerk
geruckelt hat whatever
mehr als der eigentliche Ausfall
alle Schaltjahre
mal wo wirklich was kaputt gegangen ist
da muss man mal gucken
deswegen bin ich auch Fan von
so einfach und simpel
wie geht
solange man damit alles machen kann
Deswegen bin ich auch dabei, es muss gar kein RAID sein.
Es braucht kein RAID daheim.
Es reicht voll und ganz, wenn man einmal nachts die wichtigen Daten spiegelt auf eine externe USB-Festplatte von seinem NAS.
Das braucht gar kein RAID. Unbedingt.
weil RAID, wenn man
sagt, man hat irgendwie so ein Synology
macht dann RAID 5 mit
keine Ahnung, drei oder vier Platten
das gibt dann so eine falsche Sicherheit von
ah, ich hab jetzt hier Ausfallsicherheit
und
quasi kann mir nichts
passieren, das Problem ist
RAID ist nur Ausfallsicherheit, RAID ist
nicht Backup, weil wenn du aus Versehen
was löscht auf deinem NAS, dann ist es weg
egal wie viel gespiegelte Platten du hast
hast du einmal nachts
ein AirSync oder sowas laufen
auf eine externe USB Festplatte
dann hast du das Problem nicht
und dann muss man sich fragen, brauche ich diese Ausfallsicherheit
wirklich
brauche ich die Ausfallsicherheit von einem RAID
daheim wirklich
oder ist es nicht
ausreichend
wenn ich das Ding runterfahre
die Festplatte raus mache
eine neue Festplatte rein mache
und vor meinem Backup
das wieder drauf kopiere.
Das muss man sich halt
dann überlegen.
Bei den meisten ist das eigentlich nicht notwendig.
Bei Raid kommt noch dabei,
dass Raid auch mal ganz gerne kaputt geht.
Das wird unterschätzt.
Raid 5 ist sehr fehleranfällig
beim Rebuild.
Chatgewehr hat aufgepasst.
Wie viele Platten dürfen bei Raid 5 kaputt gehen?
eine richtig eine also jetzt überlegt euch mal man hat hier so einen oder man hätte hier so
nass mit was hat das 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 slots 88 trace man kann das zeug eigentlich acht einschübe
Also überlegt euch mal, jemand macht mit 8 Platten eine Raid 5.
Die Chance, also da gab es auch so einen Calculator, Base, Base, genau.
Da gab es auch so einen Calculator, das wiegt einen so in Sicherheit.
Man darf nicht vergessen, bei 8 großen Platten ist die Chance, dass Raid 5 beim Rebuild kaputt geht,
höher als das es geht.
Bevor ich jetzt Mist erzähle,
wir gucken mal kurz, ob das wirklich stimmt.
Hier, passt mal auf.
Rate 5, Drive Size
10 Terabyte.
Da bin ich mir unsicher, was
aktuell Unrecoverable Error Rates sind.
Hier, Errorless Rebuild
Success Chance, 2%.
Die neuen Platten haben wir aber bessere.
Keine Ahnung.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, was ist denn da aktuell so.
Sieht man das irgendwo bei Seagate?
Steht da irgendwo die Error Rate dabei?
Dass wir das mal realistisch machen können.
Ups, die Seite wurde nicht gefunden.
Steht da irgendwo die Error Rate dabei?
Da muss man Datenblatt wahrscheinlich gucken.
Das war Siegel, Datenblatt.
So, wo steht die?
Fehler, muss ich mal so einen Fehler vielleicht.
Hier, 15.
1 pro 10 hoch 15.
Okay.
Siehste?
Leute.
Mit 6 Laufwerken
hast du quasi nur
eine 67% Chance,
das ist, also, für den Arsch, ja.
Eine 67% Chance,
dass dein Raid 5 fehlerfrei rebuildet.
Also das würde ich nicht benutzen.
Ja, das
wiegt ein manchmal so ein bisschen in falscher Sicherheit,
Raid. So, und jetzt machen wir mal auf 8 hoch.
Da hast du eh gelitten.
Okay, es hat nicht ganz gestimmt,
was ich gesagt habe. Ich habe gesagt, bei 8 Festplatten
ist die Chance, dass es kaputt geht, höher als
das es geht, nicht ganz.
Ja, es ist 57 zu 43%.
Aber wir können ungefähr sagen,
50-50, ja.
Und das sind so Dinge, wo man
immer im Hinterkopf behalten muss und
daran halt auch sieht, okay, manchmal
ist, wenn man
denkt, man tut sich was Gutes mit
Ausfallsicherheit, ist vielleicht
manchmal gar nicht so.
So, dann gucken wir das Video
weiter. Ist mir nur gerade dabei eingefallen.
Deswegen bin ich auch immer ein Fan von
so simpel, wie es irgendwie geht.
Router. Wie ich eben schon gesagt habe, ist das der
Asus GT AXE 16000,
der leider kein eigenes Modem
hat und deshalb an dem
DrayTag Vigor 160 hängt, was das Netzwerk...
Erlobe ich mir doch so eine publische Fritzbox.
Da ist alles drin, was du brauchst.
Und schnell genug für daheim ist es auch.
...Internet verbindet.
An den beiden 10 Gigabit-Ports des Routers hängen mein Gaming-PC
und das Synology DS1823XS+.
Gibt es nicht mittlerweile sogar eine Fritzbox mit 10 Gig?
Einem SFP-Plus-Port?
diese beiden Geräte am häufigsten größere Dateien untereinander austauschen müssen.
Zusätzlich hängt am Router aber auch noch ein iMac, auf dem ich Voice-Overs für die Videos hier aufnehme,
und ein Netzwerkswitch.
An dem Netzwerkswitch hängen wiederum drei Raspberry Pis, davon ein 5er und zwei 3er,
die WD-Mic Cloud Home, ein Aufnahmepc, dessen Aufgabe es lediglich ist,
von Test-PCs oder Grafikkarten
Footage zu capturen mit
einer Capture-Karte und dann
gibt es noch die GPU-Teststation.
Warum kann es der iMac nicht machen mit dem Capture?
... auf der ich Grafikkarten teste.
Und darüber hinaus hängen natürlich noch ein paar
andere Geräte im... Ach so, wahrscheinlich
weil er sonst so viel rumtragen müsste, ja?
Weil es
sein Testzeug
wahrscheinlich im anderen Zimmer ist.
Chat sagt, ich habe mir jetzt auf deine Empfehlung
MikroTickle, finde ich besser als Fritzbox
für mich, wenn du Funktionen
brauchst, kannst du die Fritzbox
eh vergessen, also wenn du Routing
Funktionen brauchst, ja
oder irgendwelche bisschen advancederen
Geschichten, was halt RouterOS bietet
oder auch nur gescheite VLAN-Config
da ist das natürlich
Längen besser
Die Fritzbox ist kein guter Router, die Fritzbox ist kein guter Switch, die Fritzbox ist keine gute Telefonanlage, die Fritzbox ist ein gutes Multifunktionsgerät, weil es einfach alles kann und das meiste davon ausreichend kann.
Ja, ich meine, du kriegst, ja, ja, genau, du kriegst so ein Hex-PoE zum Beispiel, kriegst du für irgendwie 40 Euro und hast mehr Möglichkeiten als bei allen anderen Consumer-Geräten und billiger.
Dafür haben die ja auch kein Modem drin
Also ich hab's bei mir so
Ich hab bei mir ne Fritzbox
Die Fritzbox die ist aber nur für VoIP
Zuständig
Die macht nur VoIP
Also deckt Basisstationen und VoIP
Und
Als zentrales Teil
Hab ich nen Mikrotik-Router bei mir
Und hier für Internet
10 Gbps
Aber der ist nicht von Mikrotik.
Das ist ein Edge-Switch.
Und die Fritz-
die spricht dann auch meine Deck-Thermostate
an. Ich habe so Fritz-Thermostate
an der Heizung.
Und das funktioniert alles ganz gut.
Hex-PoE.
Das ist der Name von einem Router.
Dieses Teil hier
Aber da gibt es mittlerweile
Neueren von, aber ich hab den
Kost, kost nix
Und
Hat
Mal gucken, was der mittlerweile kostet
Oh
Die sind aber teuer geworden
Das hat vor ein paar, das hat sich irgendwie für 45 Euro
Oder so hab ich mir den noch gekauft
Oder für 50 oder so
Den würde ich aber nicht mehr kaufen, den alten
Da gibt es mittlerweile neueren von
und du hast halt komplettes Router-OS drauf,
mit dem du alles machen kannst.
Okay, du wirst sicherlich Sachen finden, die du nicht damit machen kannst,
aber du kannst wirklich nahezu alles, was es netzwerktechnisch gibt,
mit Router-OS machen.
Guckt euch mal die Demo an, Router-OS.
Das ist allerdings nicht für den Casual-Anwender, muss man sagen.
Also, wer jetzt denkt, ey, ich brauche ein bisschen mehr Funktionen,
die man als die meine fritz box bietet ich kaufe mir so eine kiste hier mit
router os und dann machen wir das mal haben wir das mal schnell konfiguriert
also man muss sich da schon ein bisschen mit bisschen mit beschäftigen ja
mutter ist es das mikro tico es ja moment das ist neu was das was ist was
ist mtl v ab mikrotik okay das ist neu
das neue kenne ich noch gar nicht das hat meines hat mein router noch gar
nicht okay das ist im prinzip das gleiche nur das ist bis ja das ist genau
das gleiche nur dass man ein bisschen andere oberfläche hat nein nein nein
Nein, wir wollen kein Quickset Advanced
haben.
Ja, das ist eine Demo-Anwendung, die unter der Haube
nichts macht. Das ist ja nicht meins oder so.
Ja, also wer sich da mal
ein bisschen durchklicken will,
du hast wirklich alles
Mögliche hier. Ja, du kannst
Firewall-Regeln anlegen, du kannst
ähm, wo geht das?
Warte mal, bei Bridge
kann man Faulhans machen.
Also wirklich alles Mögliche.
Das Ding ist,
ein Fass ohne Boden, wenn man sich damit...
Also bei VPN bin ich mir
tatsächlich nicht sicher, ob der mittlerweile WireGuard
kann.
IPsec kann er und OpenVPN
kann er, glaube ich,
auch.
Können die auch mittlerweile?
Okay.
Ich weiß aber gar nicht, wo man das hier findet.
Wie gesagt, das ist nicht sonderlich intuitiv
zu bedienen.
gar nicht wo ihr vpn geduld ist ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht ich hätte
jetzt eigentlich gedacht bei ip ach war ja gar gibt es sogar ein
knopf oben für das wundert mich jetzt eigentlich weil hier hier ist ip sec
drin war ja gar einen eigenen knopf
ja also ihr seht schon dass es nicht ohne aber von den funktionen her ist das
preis-leistungsmäßig das beste was ihr euch holen könnt youtube video dankeschön für den
sub gibt auch wieder youtube videos sobald ich wieder normal im kopf bin oder zu battlefield
6 in einem monat und wenn ihr ein bisschen euch interessiert für netzwerktechnik und so was ist
das auch ein super einstiegs gerät muss ich vielleicht mal mit dem ein oder anderen
ding zu beschäftigen was man daheim normalerweise nicht so benutzt also uspf routing zum beispiel
du kannst auch ein hotspot konfigurieren wenn du ein gerät hast mit integriertem wlan gibt
auch ja also die haben die haben access points die haben ja sogar hier die wifi sachen drauf
access point mit router us wie gesagt die bedienung ist ein bisschen kompliziert aber
es ist preis leistungsmäßig von den funktionen ja das beste was man sich
kaufen kann auch ein guter einstieg so mit dem netzwerk technik
ja gut uspf mit nur einem gerät natürlich plötzlich das stimmt was willst du irgendwelche
routing tabellen da proper gaten wenn du nix hast du hinrufen kannst ist das eine gute alternativ
für unify unify ist ein schönes in sich geschlossen nennt man plug and play ready
system das ist das hier ist die oberfläche von einem router wurde alles
mögliche einrichten ganz mikro tic hat auch access points weiß ich nicht ob die
tauben habe ich nicht ausprobiert ich habe eine access point von mikro tic den
habe ich aber nicht hier standardmäßig am laufen den habe ich hier ab und zu
man nur zum basteln dran so ganz kleiner 20 euro access point hat aber auch gut
als drauf also eine richtige alternative unify würde ich nicht sagen aber du
kannst dein heim netzwerk natürlich ohne probleme mit mikrotik router betreiben
oder mit zwischen von mikrotik und unify anschließen unify access points
da spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen man braucht ja nicht zwangsläufig in die
Unify-Tree-Maschinen nur um Unify-Access-Points zu benutzen.
Läuft RouterOS auch auf normalen PCs?
Nee.
Ups.
So, jetzt gucken wir das Video aber endlich mal fertig.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Hey Friends, welcome back.
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein.
Drei.
Sind das blöd? Wo habe ich das Video hin? Ach da!
Paintstrap.
Ja, Cisco Geräte, wenn man sich damit beschäftigen will, bleibt eigentlich nur Emulation.
Dass man sich, gibt ja, oh, virtuelles Netzwerk gebastelt.
Früher haben wir dafür immer Packet... Wie hieß das Ding?
Was wir damals beim CCNA verwendet haben, Packet Tracer, kann das sein? Packet Tracer, ja, beste, richtig geil. Aber es gibt ja mittlerweile auch so virtuelle Netzwerking-Geschichten, wo du dann vor Ems mit Router-Firmware startest und sowas.
Ja, oder, genau, GLS3 und sowas habe ich aber nie großartig verwendet. Packet Tracer ist super. Es gibt kaum was besseres, ohne Scheiß, Leute. Wenn ihr euch mit Netzwerktechnik beschäftigen wollt oder wenn ihr eine Physieausbildung macht und euch wirklich mal genau angucken wollt, wie läuft das Ganze, ja, wenn PCA zu PCB will, so mit einem Abrequest und dann irgendwie ein TCP-SYN-Package und sowas, dann holt euch Packet Tracer.
Tracer. Es gibt kein
besseres Tool, um das zu verstehen.
Da kannst du nämlich sogar, ich kann euch das sogar mal zeigen.
Kann man das hier
irgendwie sehen? Packet Tracer.
Gibt es das?
Ja, gibt es. Ich mach mal kurz
einen
Snapshot, weil
ich keine Ahnung habe, was ich da für komisches Zeug installiere.
Packet Tracer.
Beste. Was?
Not found.
Oh ne
Hä
Wie jetzt doch jetzt
Bin ich
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt
Was not found
Ja wie jetzt
Aber erstmal schön die Dependencies installiert
Geil
Was not found
Äh kann ich sagen
make clean oder irgendwie sowas package zu bilden okay dann mal kein packet
tracer packet tracer download gratis
braucht man nicht den account braucht man das weiß gar nicht gucken wir mal
download packet tracer beim bloggen ok
sign up 10 minute mail fake account country aserbaidschan die kommt wir
machen mal wir machen wirklich germany weil ansonsten ist es auch wegen der
sprache ja hier da genau da sind wir geboren continue peter agilie passwort
ok
passte
Alter, will er mich verarschen?
Ich hab doch alles drin.
Ich hab ein Lowercase Letter, ich hab ein Uppercase Letter.
Ich hab ne Number.
Ah, ein Special Character hab ich nicht.
Okay.
Darf ich jetzt?
Ja, okay, nice.
Ne, das sieht nur so aus.
Jaja.
Ich stimme dazu.
Okay, darf ich jetzt Packet Tracer runterladen, please?
Packet Tracer?
Moment, das gibt es nur für Ubuntu?
auch nie jetzt kann das nicht mal installieren
ach scheiß drauf dann nicht ich kann euch sagen wenn ihr netzwerktechnik
zeug ausprobiert wollt nehmt packet tracer beste warum ist denn das packet
tracer ding kaputt
Hier 19.8.
Blablup.
Broken.
Das Auer packt das Depp aus.
Ja und macht da noch irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die ich jetzt nicht von Hand machen will.
Naja.
Dann nicht.
Wir packen das Debian-Package jetzt auch mal aus.
Vielleicht kann man sie einfach starten.
Gucken wir mal.
Hast du noch Kontakte aus der früheren COD-Zeit?
Eigentlich nicht.
Kaboom ewig nichts gehört.
Was aber an mir lag, ich bin ja sozial so voll unfähig.
Der hatte mal angerufen vor 2-3 Jahren.
Ich hab's erst zu spät gesehen und dann hab ich nicht zurückgerufen und so.
Dabei mag ich den.
Echt gern.
So, also.
Was essen das überhaupt?
Debian Package.
Wie ein Target Set.
wie an wie wie anpackt man denn den db hat
package
How to unpack
Jetzt ist es raus was da x was
Das ist kein Target Set.
Ja.
R-Command.
What?
R.
X.
So, da haben wir.
Und da ist jetzt ein Target Set drin.
What the fuck?
Ich habe das alles schon mal irgendwo gesehen, aber...
Moment, XZ.
Und das einfach nur, obwohl ich euch kurz Packet Tracer zeigen wollte.
Meine Güte.
User, Share, Icons.
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Wo ist denn jetzt das Binary?
Opt?
Opt Packet Tracer?
Packet Tracer, da ist es doch
Seriously?
Nee
Jetgear
Das müsst ihr euch ohne mich angucken, Packet Tracer
Ist doch Snapshot
Guck jetzt das Video fertig
Ähm
Die Dependencies hatte ich ja alle installiert
Ja, gibt kein Packet Tracer
Aber ich muss mal gucken, dass ich das wieder installiert krieg
Weil Packet Tracer ist ein wirklich geiles Tool
Da könnt ihr
Ich kann euch ein Bild davon zeigen hier
Ähm
Packet Tracer
Da könnt ihr quasi Netzwerke malen
so grafisch
und dann könnt ihr euch wirklich die einzelnen
Pakete angucken, die zu welchem
Zeitpunkt hier drüber von Router
zu Router zu Rechner und das hat
auch so einen Step-by-Step
Modus, da kann man dann sagen
okay, Paket von der
ersten Station zur zweiten Station, von der zweiten Station
zur dritten Station, kann man sich alles angucken
Layer 2 Header,
Layer 3 Geschichte, Layer 4 Sachen bis zu
HTTP hoch, also wenn man wirklich
Netzwerksachen verstehen will, ist Packet Tracer
das Beste.
Hast du nicht eine Windows vorhanden?
Doch!
Aber ich habe keinen Bock jetzt, nochmal eine halbe Stunde rumzumachen.
Wir gucken, das Video ist fertig.
Im WLAN, wie zum Beispiel die beiden Echo Dots und die Hue Bridge hängt auch noch am Router.
Das sind dann aber für mich eher nette Add-ons als wirklich ernsthafte Geräte, um damit zu arbeiten.
Und der eine oder andere, der wird sich sicherlich fragen, was macht man mit so vielen Geräten im Netzwerk?
Die kurze Antwort lautet, ich nutze diese Geräte im Netzwerk für mich selbst,
um unabhängig zu sein und um Dinge zu machen, für die man sonst in Form eines unnötigen Abo-Modells monatlich zahlen müsste.
Die Zentrale des Ganzen ist immer noch das Synology NAS,
in dem ich momentan insgesamt 90 TB Festplattenspeicher habe und 2 TB SSD-Speicher als Cache.
Und auf dem befindet sich erstmal das gesamte Kreativecke-Videoarchiv.
Jeder Videoschnipsel, jedes Voice-Over, einfach alles, was ich jemals für diesen Kanal aufgenommen habe.
Ich bin ja immer neidisch, wenn ich sehe, wie es Leute schaffen, so ordentlich zu sein.
Wenn ihr wüsstet, wie mein Videoordner aussieht, da findet ihr nichts drin.
...befindet sich genau da drauf.
Und das ist eben auch wichtig, damit wir immer mal wieder auch Zugriff auf ältere Aufnahmen haben.
Das NAS ist aber nicht nur Datengrab, sondern viel mehr.
Auf dem NAS laufen zum Beispiel wichtige Dienste.
Beispielsweise hoste ich meine eigene Cloud.
Ich hatte keine Lust mehr auf OneDrive oder 90TB bei Linux, Isos, ja klar.
Dropbox und was es sonst noch alles gibt, weshalb ich mich dazu entschieden habe, meinen eigenen Cloud-Dienst zu hosten mit Nextcloud.
Das läuft auf dem...
Ja, Nextcloud ist Schrott.
Ich mag Nextcloud nicht.
Ihr wisst, dass ich von Nextcloud nichts halte.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich Nextcloud nicht verwenden darf oder so.
Ich mag Nextcloud nicht.
Nextcloud ist so ein
unfertiges Sammelsurium von
allem möglichen
ich glaube das trifft es ganz gut
und eine
Cloudlösung
ist es ja auch nicht
letztendlich Cloud
bedeutet für mich immer
es ist irgendeine Art und Weise was verteiltes
ja
ist es ja auch nicht
Synology NAS in einem eigenen
Container und damit habe ich dann nicht nur
zugriff von überall auf meine eigene cloud zumindest an geräten die browser
haben sondern auch was ist besser naja wenn du das komplett paket brauchst
nichts ansonsten
wenn den fall zwingt brauchst
irgendwie sowas wie sing sing oder
etwas anderes keine ahnung
Ich habe es bei mir noch installiert, weil ich da vor Jahren mal angefangen habe, meine Kontakte drin zu speichern.
Ich hatte immer noch keinen Bock, einen eigenen Caldav-Server hinzustellen.
Aber für sonst benutze ich es eigentlich nicht.
Und ich mag es nicht.
Schon oft genug gesagt.
Zum Beispiel von meinem Smartphone aus über die Nextcloud App.
Und das Beste ist, meine ganzen Dateien werden mit allen Geräten in einer sauberen Ordnerstruktur synchronisiert.
Und apropos, was ihr vielleicht gerade in der iPhone-Aufnahme gesehen habt, sind...
Was synkt der denn da alles? Von alles wird es ja nicht sein, das ist ja viel zu viel.
Viele Aufnahmen von Pokémon-Karten. Das ist neben Technik meine zweite Lieblingsleidenschaft.
Ich sammle Pokémon-Karten und habe für meine eigene Sammlung eine eigene Datenbank angelegt.
Ich habe das Ganze mit PHP My Admin als Datenbank aufgebaut und dann eine kleine Web-App gebastelt.
Ich weiß, das sieht aus wie von 1998, aber es geht ja nur darum, dass ich...
Das sieht nicht aus wie von 1998.
Es hat ein Dark Theme.
Allein schon, wenn was ein Dark Theme hat, ist es besser als 1998.
Ich persönlich einen Überblick über meine Sammlung behalte und auch eben immer mal wieder schauen kann, was sind diese Karten eigentlich wert, weil die sind echt nicht günstig.
Genauso wie ich zum Beispiel auch gerne den Überblick über meine Ausgaben behalte mit einer Datenbank und einem kleinen Haushaltsbuch in Form von einer Web-App, die ich auch selbst gebastelt habe.
Ich finde das cool, dass er so viel selbst programmiert hat.
Es gibt für alles garantiert schon was Fertiges, aber es geht ja bei sowas auch immer ein bisschen ums Lernen, um den Basteldrang, den man so hat.
... habe und das wird auch alles von meinem Nas aus gehostet.
Denn eines ist mir ganz wichtig, so Sachen wie der Wert meiner Pokémon-Karten oder auch irgendwie so meine Ausgaben, die gehen gar keinen App-Betreiber irgendetwas an.
Also ich will das privat halten.
Und wisst ihr, was noch keinen etwas angeht, aber super komfortabel über eine eigene Cloud zu betreiben ist?
Ein papierloses Büro mit paperless NGX.
Sobald ich einen Brief bekomme oder ein...
Ah, ich dachte, jetzt kommt das persönliche YouPorn-Archiv.
Dokument anfertige, scanne ich das Dokument und es wird automatisch bei
Paperless NGX hinterlegt oder ich sende es vom PC aus und wenn ich dann mal ganz
schnell ein Dokument brauche, dann schafft man es mit dem Programm intern
nach Schlagworten zu suchen, die sich in dem Dokument befinden, was absolut
genial ist, weil man sofort alles findet und das ohne... Ich hab das auch mal
ausprobiert. Ich war da zu faul für... Ich fang... Vielleicht kennt ihr das, ich fang
immer so mit guten vorsätzen an wenn ich so eine software finde benutzt es dann eine woche und dann
schläft ein weil ich zu faul bin blätter und wer jetzt meint okay das ist ja alles schön und gut
aber irgendwie auch ein bisschen langweilig also ich meine so papierkram und so ist halt nicht so
cool aber schaut mal was ich hier gerade mache ich lasse bilder von einem server raum von einer
ki generieren so weit so gut erstmal nichts spannendes aber diese ki läuft lokal stable
Diffusion. Okay, zugegeben.
Ich kann dir sagen, Asparius,
du bist nicht der Einzige.
Wir haben hier ganz viele
ehemalige Codkillers
am Start.
Die da jetzt auch alle schon ein bisschen rausgewachsen sind.
Aber viele.
Mal kurz was gucken.
Five Nights, danke für den Sub, weil ich es noch nicht gesagt habe.
Nicht auf dem NAS, sondern auf meinem Hauptsystem, weil ich da natürlich auch eine Grafikkarte drin habe, auf der die Direktdaten laufen.
Aber auch das hoste ich lokal und habe von überall Zugriff da drauf.
Und jetzt steht noch eine Frage aus. Wie greife ich eigentlich von der Ferne...
Okay.
Ich rate mal
Der benutzt bestimmt
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen hin und her gerissen
Zwischen, der hat eine Wireguard Lösung
Oder Tailscale
Tailscale, ich sage auch Tailscale
Talescale.
...aus auf diese ganzen Dienste zu.
Ich habe mich dagegen entschieden, Ports nach außen zu öffnen, aber ich...
Das ist schon mal keine schlechte Idee.
Ich habe eine super Lösung gefunden über einen VPN mit TaliScale.
Das heißt auch, dass alle diese Geräte in einem Virtual Private Network hängen
und über TaliScale kann ich dann quasi unbegrenzt neue Geräte registrieren
und das ohne Ports öffnen zu müssen.
Für die Zukunft plane ich aber noch so einige Dinge, die ich lokal hosten möchte.
Darunter Gameserver, einen eigenen Passwortmanager, denn ich nutze keine Passwortmanager,
weil ich meine Passwörter ungerne einem anderen Unternehmen anvertraue.
Und auch einen Medienserver.
Da bin ich ihm komplett recht.
Aber das Geile ist, mit so einer Netzwerkstruktur sind die Möglichkeiten fast grenzenlos.
Und das ist auch das Geile am Homelabbing.
Und dafür braucht ihr auch kein 3000 Euro teures NAS.
Man kann gar nicht...
2950 reicht.
Ganz einfach anfangen mit einem ganz simplen Raspberry Pi und dann nach und nach das Homelab einfach erweitern.
Und darum ging es mir auch mit dem Video hier.
Ich wollte euch einfach mal oberflächlich zeigen, wie geil Homelabbing ist und dass die Möglichkeiten fast grenzenlos sind.
Und dass eben fast alles privatisiert ist, ohne irgendwelche dämlichen Abo-Modelle.
Klar kostet das dann Geld, wenn man...
Also, ich, ähm, find das gut.
ich sehe das genauso
wenn man Daten nicht rausgibt
hat man
auch wenn es irgendwelche Leaks gibt, keine Probleme
darf natürlich nicht vergessen
für sehr viele Leute
ist es natürlich
schwierig
Raspberry Pi sich daheim
hinzustellen, mal Linux
draufzuhauen und damit was zu machen
also die Grundvoraussetzung ist natürlich
dass man sich für Technik
interessiert und ein bisschen was lernen will und nicht ganz so schnell gefrustet ist aber dann ist
es nice und speicher kauft aber dieses geld zahlt ihr ja dann in der cloud sowieso also nicht einfach
aufbauen weil es einfach ist auf einen schlag bezahlen und dann nie wieder und jetzt frage
ich euch habt ihr irgendwelche tipps weil ich steige ja auch selbst erst so richtig in das
Thema Homelabbing ein? Wenn ja, ab damit
in die Kommentare. Wenn euch dieses Video
gefallen hat, dann freue ich mich über einen Daumen in nördlicher
Richtung. Schaut auch gerne mal bei meinen
letzten Videos vorbei. Ich würde sagen, wir sehen uns
im nächsten Video wieder. Ich bin raus. Ciao!
Also, weil es gerade dabei passt,
so sieht es bei mir im Serverraum
aus.
Ja.
Wir sind mal wieder im Serverraum.
So sieht es bei mir aus. Also mein Kabelmanagement ist jetzt auch nicht so viel besser.
Da hatte ich noch Unify. Guck mal, da hatte ich noch ein Unify Access Point hier in der Ecke stehen.
da sieht man meinen Krempel oben in der 3D Drucker
mit einer selbst gedruckten RGB Lampe
meine Werkzeugwand
oben steht ein Raspberry Pi drauf
der steht immer noch da. 10 Gbps Switch. Letztendlich sieht man es ja hier.
Ich zeige euch mal ein bisschen das Kram. Tablet, Stealth. Was auch immer ich jetzt hier auf dem Tablet mache.
Eine der wenigen beschrifteten Sachen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich irgendwo noch den Inhalt vom Rack zeige.
Ja, 10 Gbps Switch.
Im Vergleich zu dem Asus Switch sind das echte 10 Gbps an jedem Port.
Hat glaube ich 12 oder so SFP Plus Ports, 4 Kupfer Ports.
Den Switch finde ich auch immer noch top.
Es war eines der ersten so halbwegs erschwinglichen 10 Gig Switch, die es gab und er ist immer noch gut.
Was hast du jetzt als Access Point?
Ruckus.
Ruckus Access Points habe ich.
Ich habe bei Ebay gekauft, gebraucht.
Für so ungefähr 250 Euro das Stück.
Da habe ich zwei Stück.
Und einen zum Basteln.
Weil es den günstig gab.
R710.
die sind schon ein bisschen älter mittlerweile kriegst du halbwegs
erschwinglich auch schon die neuere generation
generation
mit 95 das ding hat ganz hat ordentlich power
ja 10 gbps unten drunter so eine art patch panel wo die hälfte angeschlossen
usv aber ansonsten hier großartig einstiegs steckdosenleiste hier so eine schublade mit
der fritz box und dem mikrotec router drauf aber das noch schauen auch noch eine stunde
zeit wir können noch einiges gucken gaspedal stadt fahrradpedal die partei schützt die autos
Ne, wir gucken das andere.
Das andere mit dem,
mit dem, wo sie sich über die
zu schnellen Fahrradfahrer aufregen.
So, da.
Und ach, das ist noch die alte Kiste.
Die habe ich gar nicht mehr.
Die habe ich schon ewig
nicht mehr, die alte Kiste.
Und die USV
habe ich auch nicht mehr.
Das ist ja richtig, richtig alt.
Ist das hier neuer?
Ja, da ist aber nur das Webinterface.
Hier, Umbau.
Sieht man da vielleicht ein bisschen was?
Ne, da ist auch noch das alte Ding.
Ich hab nix mit dem neuen Aufbau.
wird mal zeit wie lange die usv beim stromausfall ich habe das nie ausprobiert
also bewusst habe ich schon immer ganz kurz abgestöpselt
er war irgendwie rum gebaut hat oder so beim stromausfall weiß ich nicht die usv war aber
schrott weil die usv ausgegangen ist als die batterie kaputt gegangen gegangen ist
und die batterie altersschwäche gestorben ist und das obwohl die usv noch am netz
hing das fand ich ziemlich schrottig jetzt habe ich so eine billige apc usv
und die hat das problem nicht
usv gibt es ja relativ günstig finde ich jetzt gar nicht so schlimm eigentlich
hast du lte empfangen wenn strom wegbricht habe ich aber
ich glaube ein stromausfall ist für die kurze zeit brauche ich kein internet backup irgendeine
Art und Weise.
Mit was
sollte ich es denn dann benutzen?
Mein Rechner geht ja dann auch nicht.
Und die Handys, die haben
ja selbst Mobilfunk drin.
Naja.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Eleven new CSS Features.
ist da überhaupt irgendwas dabei was mich interessiert light dark theme pop
over api diff colors content visibility auto online content und blog layout
lohnt sich raid für private sicherung schön dass du fragst da habe ich mich
vorher schon lange darüber ausgelassen aus meiner sicht ist raid schon mal für
sicherung gar nicht gedacht sondern nur für ausfallsicherheit also wenn du rate
als backup ersatz verwenden willst ist eine schlechte idee weil wenn du auf
deinem rate was löscht ist es weg auch wenn du aus versehen was löschst
das kann hier bei einem backup nicht passieren und ansonsten wenn du sagst ja
ich will ausfallsicherheit haben so dass auch meine platte ausfallen kann kannst
raid benutzen muss ja aber nur im klaren sein was zu finden raid benutzt und mit
wieviel platten weil ich habe es vorhin gezeigt haben es hier noch einmal raid
error calculator wenn du nämlich in raid 5 nimmst was viele leute benutzen
mit 5 mit zehn terabyte platten da hast du schon einmal so hast du schon
einmal wenn du sechs platten in das raid 55 haust hast du schon mal eine 33
prozentige chance dass der rebuild nicht klappt und das ist natürlich schlecht
33 prozent chance das ding im arsch ist nicht gut wenn du runter gehst mit den
mit den geräten mit den platten dann wird es ein bisschen besser aber du
siehst selbst bei drei platten also 15 prozent wahrscheinlichkeit dass sein
Raid im Arsch ist danach.
Das ist schon Schrott, oder?
Also Raid 6 ist natürlich deutlich
besser, was das angeht, aber da brauchst du dann auch wieder
zwei Platten für. Also zwei Platten
verschwendest du vom Platz her.
Deswegen, ganz ehrlich,
wenn Raid,
mache ich eigentlich nur noch Raid 1.
Alpha Raid 1.
gespiegelt fertig
nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee
cheat 95, du hast das falsch verstanden
das sind keine
das sind keine 67%
oder 33%
Ausfall
nee, nee, der Ausfall wird zu 100%
abgefangen
aber dann musst du ja dann
Raid rebuilden
du tauscht dann die Platte aus
und machst eine neue Platte rein
und dann kackt der Rebuild ab.
Weil irgendwas auf irgendeiner der beteiligten Platten nicht lesbar ist.
Und dann musst du möglichst gucken,
dass du, weil du hast ja dann keine Redundanz mehr
und du hast unrecoverable Sachen auf irgendeiner Festplatte,
fehler was irgendwie so schnell wie möglich seine daten abzieht in der
hoffnung das geht noch und irgendwo speichert deswegen nächtliches backup
ersetzt das nicht
Gut das stimmt wohl aber zfs reagiert allergisch gegen
Fehler
Beim rebuild aber da hast du ja auch andere schutzmechanismen dass das eigentlich so gut wie keine fehler gibt
SSDs für Backup? Ne, hängt in der Festplatte dran, externe USB Festplatte.
Aber generell ist ZFS eh sehr POC, wenn auch ziemlich komplex.
Genau, so sieht's aus.
Wenn du einfach nur auf Nummer sicher gehen willst, dass du keine Daten verlierst,
dann scheiß auf RAID, nimm die zweite Festplatte lieber als externe Backup-Platte.
machen eine 10 terabyte platte rein oder was auch immer gerade günstig ist hängen wir noch
mal eine 10 terabyte platte per usb dran oder kannst auch einbauen ist egal und dann lässt
er einmal nachts einfach ein backup laufen von deinem das quasi auf deine zweite platte
natürlich kannst du auch ein bisschen advanced machen kannst dir eine backup software suchen
was dann so dinger wie einmal jeden tag und dann nur noch eins aufheben für eine woche und dann
eins aus einem monat und da gibt es ja gibt es ja keine grenzen bei der reinen lehre nach sollte man
ja wenn es ums thema backup geht sollte man die 321 strategie befolgen chat wer kennt die 321
strategie macht eh keiner da ist dabei
glaube das ist es ja ich habe euch gerade ein bisschen gebetet ich wusste
nämlich selbst mal nicht mehr genau wofür die 321 strategie steht aber ich
bin es cool dass ihr das wisst da muss ich das nicht wissen
ich wusste noch dass es was mit offside backup ist und dreimal vor ort vor
halten und so was in der richtung aber wie genau also damit ist gemeint man
soll die dateien dreimal quasi drei kopien von der datei haben irgendwie auf
Wie geht das? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Und einmal aufsammeln.
3, 2, 1, Backup.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Guck mal.
Wenn uns das Ding hier schon erklären muss.
Ist es nicht 1 und 1?
Ja, steht für
dreifache Ausführung der Dateien.
Okay, da habe ich schon mal richtig.
Zwei verschiedene Medientypen.
Und eine Kopie
aus der Haus. Genau.
Moin Ikari. Schön, dass du da bist. Ja, aber das macht eh kaum einer. Also ich denke, wenn man nächtlich ein Backup macht und eventuell sogar noch ein zusätzliches Cloud Backup hat, wenn aber überhaupt dann nur voll verschlüsselt, ja, dann kann eigentlich so gut wie nichts passieren.
Weil dann hat man die Daten ja quasi auf seinem Rechner noch, man hat die Daten auf dem NAS, da sind die ja auch noch drauf, dann hat man sie einmal nachts gebackupt, also da musst du ja schon die Bude abfackeln und dafür hast du im Zweifelsfall noch ein Offside-Backup.
auf sein backup heißt ja nicht unbedingt dass das in der cloud sein muss
theoretisch kannst du es auch auf der festplatte speichern und den stall legen
oder so was natürlich von dem handling her bis
eklig ist keine ahnung kennen wir aktuell nicht aus was ich da lohnt ja
also privat wird sich genau wird es auch nicht machen
Was ist denn?
Der schnellste Kabelanschluss Deutschlands.
2000 Mbit Bonding mit...
Oh ne, das ist jetzt zu viel.
High IQ Zeug.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Windows 10 Ende. So einfach geht es zu Linux.
Ja gut.
ISO auf den USB Stick.
USB-Stick rein
oder drinnen lassen, rebooten
Linux installieren
Ja, ihr könnt das bei mir lagern, wenn ihr wollt
Ich bin bestimmt auch günstiger
Ich meine, ihr kriegt von mir jetzt keine
Wie nennt man denn
SLRs in so einem Storage-Bereich?
Ist ja wirklich, es ist ja kein SLA.
Wie heißt denn das, wenn beispielsweise
ein Anbieter garantiert, so nach dem Motto
so und so viel
Raumtemperatur und so und so viel
was weiß ich, Zugangsgeschützt
und
sowas gibt's bei mir nicht.
Aber bei mir ist es billig, wenn ihr die im Schrank
lagern wollt, äh, nicht im Schrank,
im Stall lagern wollt.
Wie verschlüsse ich die
Flachsplatte, wenn ich drei verschiedene Betriebssysteme
nutze,
dann wäre
wahrscheinlich die sinnvollste
Variante,
nicht die gesamte Platte zu
verschlüsseln, sondern nur die jeweilige
Partition.
Windows kannst du mit Veracrypt
verschlüsseln und
Linux kannst du ganz normal mit
ja unter der Haube
ist es Lux verschlüsseln.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich besser sein.
Tipp ich jetzt mal drauf.
Ich hatte noch nie drei Betriebssysteme parallel mit Verschlüsselung.
Wie das mit Mac geht, habe ich hier keinen Plan.
Nivera Clip gibt es nicht für Linux.
das wüsste ich das nicht
realisiert zum beispiel gaming in einer vm warum soll ich das machen gaming passiert hier auf dem
host
das ist doch deine antwort
temperatur stabil luftfeuchtigkeit kontrolliert soll sie schon anbieten
Jaja.
In meinem Stall ist, glaube ich, nichts garantiert.
Außer, dass es ab und zu reintropft.
Hackerman-Streams.
Ich habe eine gute Idee für einen...
für einen...
Hackerman-Bastel-Stream.
Wisst ihr, was ich schon die ganze Zeit mir überlege?
Was ich mal...
Was ich mal machen will?
Ich würde gerne eine Webseite bauen,
wie 1999.
Aber nicht etwa,
dass die so aussieht wie 1999,
sondern mit den Tools von
1999 und der Browser-Version
von 1999.
Also dann nehmen wir sowas wie hier
Macromedia
Dreamweaver
nehmen wir da.
Hier, beste.
Dreamweaver,
was auch immer 1999 angesagt war.
Ja, ich werde dazu Windows 98 installieren.
In der VM.
Ja, das würde ich gerne mal machen.
Ne, und Front...
Wir können es ja mit Frontpage und Dreamweaver.
Da müssen wir...
Webseiten damals
wurden ja noch gemacht
mit Tabeldesign.
der jahr wieder sagt 19 zahligen erfahrung und dann mit mit netz geld mit netz geld gucken wir
uns die seite an nummer für alle die das ding nicht kennen stream wie war war wirklich für
die damalige zeit massive park das hatte javascript wobei ab wann gab es überhaupt javascript
Moment
Also 1999 wird es das schon gegeben sein
Weil ich kann mich noch daran erinnern
Wir hatten damals
Ein Counter-Strike Clan
In
Counter-Strike, was war das?
052 oder sowas
Und damals haben wir eine Webseite
Dafür gebaut und da haben wir auch schon ein bisschen
Kleines JavaScript Gedöns gebastelt
Und das muss dann irgendwie so
irgendwie in dem Dreh gewesen sein.
Wann kam denn,
seit wann gab es denn JavaScript?
96 oder irgendwie sowas?
Ja, 95, ja.
Front Page, ob das der erste
visi editor bekannt von seiner frontpage war wirklich grausam hier aber dream
weaver dream weaver war wirklich geil für die damalige zeit ich leider sieht
man das ja auf den screenshot gibt es das eigentlich kann man das eigentlich
noch runterladen
die haben den campion gekauft man finde dass man finde das bestimmt noch man
findet hat bestimmt noch altes altes zeug das einsteiger seminar trieb über 4
weil der hatte damals schon also man konnte damit auch so wie sie weg mäßig
klicken aber das habe ich eigentlich nie gemacht
der hatte einen ziemlich guten editor für die damalige zeit ja somit
Syntax Highlighting, der hat sowohl HTML als auch JavaScript auto-completed. Das Ding war seinerzeit voraus. Das war der beste Editor of Website damals.
Das war wirklich extrem POG.
Wurden die ganzen Strichmännchen falls nicht mit Dreamweaver gemacht, keine Ahnung, kann schon sein.
mit mit java applet monka es aber aber zumindest mit diesem laufenden pling texte gab
ich soll ein abo kaufen seriously
mir war gar nicht bewusst dass es überhaupt noch gibt wie alt ist da
Die letzte Version.
2025? Okay.
Gibt es noch Leute, die das heutzutage benutzen?
Weil heutzutage
gibt es eigentlich überhaupt keinen Grund mehr
Dreamweaver zu benutzen.
Seit Zwischelstudio Code gibt.
macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn
aber gut
gibt's halt noch
ich bin übrigens immer noch nicht fertig
mit Essen Leute ich laber einfach zu viel
hast bestimmt ne CD im Schrank
ich hab wahrscheinlich noch ne selbstgebrannte CD
hier ja
kann ich mir vorstellen
mit ner legit Dreamweaver Version
natürlich
Nee, ich habe alle meine CDs weggeschmissen
Ich habe keine
Ich habe keine alten CDs mehr
Stimmt, stimmt, du hast recht
Netscape hatte auch so einen Editor dabei
Generell muss man ja sagen, der alte Netscape
Der hatte so komische grüne Buttons
So mit so komischen
Ja, nee
Ja, das da
Ich meine aber das hier
Diese
Diese Buttons hier oben
Netscape
Netscape war schon nice für die damalige Zeit
Happy Tree Friends
Alter, das ist ja wirklich
uraltes Zeug.
Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
Bestimmt gibt es da ab und zu immer noch was.
Es war noch Zeit. Mir läuft gerade übelst die Nase.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Es war auch die Zeit, wo man noch in Foren unterwegs war.
Heutzutage ist ja alles Reddit.
Ach ja.
So, haben wir noch irgendwas?
Wir gucken uns jetzt das hier an.
Wir gucken jetzt Windows 10 Ende.
So einfach geht es zu Linux.
Die Videos kann man mal gut gucken von denen.
Bei meinem eigentlich noch ziemlich gut funktionierenden Windows PC
poppt auf einmal diese Meldung auf.
Ja.
Ich habe übrigens auch hier Windows 10 noch.
Wann ist nochmal Support Ende?
Ist das nicht jetzt irgendwann?
Müsste ich vielleicht auch mal auf Windows 11 upgraden, ne?
25. Oktober.
Ha.
Ach, da steht es ja sogar.
Ab dem 14. Oktober.
Bei mir kam auch noch keine Meldung.
Windows 11 geht nicht, wegen zu alter Hardware.
Und Windows 10 Update gibt es ab dem 14. Oktober 2025 auch nicht mehr.
Also ich spreche hier nicht von irgendwelchen Schönheitsupdates, sondern von nicht mehr gestopften Sicherheitslöhnen.
Also ernsthaft.
Würde es das Windows 10 die letzte Windows-Version sein sollte?
Ja, ich weiß, Microsoft hat es ja nie selbst so richtig gesagt, aber man hat das schon hingenommen.
Gefährlich. Ich übersetze mal in normale Sprache, was Microsoft da sagt.
Ja, diesen Computer kannst du leider nicht mehr benutzen. Sorry. Musst du dir einen neuen kaufen.
In diesem Video zeige ich euch, wie ihr diesen von Microsoft verschmähten Computer dann noch viele Jahre sicher und sehr wahrscheinlich schwupsiger als mit Windows nutzen könnt.
Ja, habt ihr euch wahrscheinlich gedacht, wir installieren Linux, genau genommen Linux Mint.
Das wird von CT3003 und auch unserem CT-Mutterschrift.
Und witzigerweise, Overwatch wird wahrscheinlich nicht drauf gehen, oder?
Wegen Anti-Cheat.
Rate ich jetzt einfach mal.
Geht Overwatch unter Linux?
Works very well.
Aha.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Cool.
Für Leute empfohlen, die von Windows umsteigen wollen.
Ich habe das auf zwei Rekordmessern.
Ich habe schon Windows, ja, guck mal hier, Windows 11, siehst du doch.
Ja, alles Windows 11.
Aber ich habe auf dem zweiten Rechner, der hier neben mir steht, ist noch Windows 10.
... beide schon ziemlich alt und was ich in diesem Video versuchen will, die Linux-Installationen so zu zeigen, dass das wirklich alle hinbekommen.
Also ohne irgendwelche Front- und Vorne- bis hinten, also ohne dass man sich wundert, wir sind nie da jetzt hingekommen.
Das Video richtet sich also an alle...
... Linux-Installationen haben wir schon oft genug gesehen.
... auf dem sie Linux Mint installieren wollen.
Außerdem erzähle ich euch auch noch kurz, was ihr außer Linux installieren könnt, wenn eure Hardware angeblich zu alt ist, um Linux-Installationen zu machen.
auf Windows 11 abzudaten. Bleibt dran.
Ja, wenn ihr euch für Linux interessiert,
dann habt ihr Datenschutz
bestimmt auch auf der Liste.
Habt ihr das ja eigentlich schon mal geguckt?
Ja, ne? Was verdient ein IT-Systemadministrator?
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
100 Pro haben wir schon geguckt.
Heute installieren wir drei Server.
die zeller musik ja und die guten hp kisten war doch von der farbe hp oder
habe ich so richtig im kopf
ihr wisst das doch bestimmt
das ist super mikro wirklich aber die hp hat auch so eine farbe
Nee
Klisch
Das ist super mikro
Also die an den alten dl3 80
So ein alter ja ja ja okay mittlerweile mittlerweile sind die grün okay
aber die alten
Hier sieht man so ein bisschen von der farbe keiner alt
was bin ich hier sehen guck so sah die dinge früher vorne aus die waren auch so rot jetzt
jetzt ist es aber nicht mehr so
super mikro
warum habe ich da unten kein sollte ich nicht da so weil ich
Da hätte ich so Bock wieder mal
Einfach ins Rechenzentrum
Mit so einem schönen Wagen
Ein paar Server reinfahren
Schienen einbauen
Server einbauen
Danach noch ein paar Kabel oben ans Patchpanel
Dann vorne gucken wo man es anschließt
Da hätte ich so richtig Bock mal wieder drauf
Ein bisschen was zu bauen im Rechenzentrum
Ja genau, diese Befestigungsdinger, irgendwie Finger stechen und sowas oder Fingernagel
dran abbrechen und sowas.
Gatschibass.
Da hätte ich so Bock wieder drauf, ein bisschen zu bauen, Rechenzentrum.
Kennt ihr diese Wagen, die man, diese, nicht wirklich Sackkarren, diese Rechenzentrumswagen, die es da so gibt, kann das nicht beschreiben.
Da habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden, warum die Lenkung von den Wagen hinten ist anstatt vorne.
So kann man die überhaupt nicht schieben, man kann die nur ziehen, gescheit.
Die PewDiePie-Videos.
Ja, nett, du kannst die Dinger nicht lenken, das funzt nicht.
Nee, umdrehen und dann schieben geht nicht.
Weil du hast ja den Griff nur an einer Seite.
Naja.
Was geht jetzt ab?
Ja, gut.
Heute beobachten wir eine Fahrt.
Das zeigt nicht,
lasst uns die Verbindung beobachten.
Das ist ja wohl die, die, die, ich weiß nicht was das für eine Stimme ist, aber eines der verbreitetsten Text-to-Speech-Stimmen überhaupt.
Ja, also Sachen wieder einstecken ist nicht verkehrt.
Conformation.
Das hat das Problem gelöst.
Ah, ich weiß nicht
Keine Ahnung
Ah
Ist ja was, Leute
Ich geh jetzt runter und hol mir noch ein Trostbrot
Ich hab Hunger
Deswegen mach ich jetzt Schluss
Ich bin morgen ganz normal, ganz normal, als wäre es normal, dass ich online komme.
Ja, ich bin morgen wahrscheinlich ganz normal wieder für Nachmittag streamen da.
Morgen muss ich nach Frankfurt fahren.
Morgen ist Präsenzstelz auf der Arbeit.
Da weiß ich nicht, ob ich morgen on komme.
Ja.
Läuft mit der Bahn.
Das wird wieder ganz schlimm morgen werden.
Ich habe gehört, Deutschland-Ticket
gibt es größere Diskussionen, wie das finanziert werden soll.
Ey, wenn die das wirklich
abschaffen, ne?
Sieht ja nicht danach aus, aber dann drehe ich echt am Rad.
Weil
das ist eines der wenigen Sachen,
wo ich mal wirklich gemerkt habe,
da wurde was gemacht, was mir
persönlich was bringt.
Hatte ich so noch nie, ja.
Genau, und das einzig Gute, Alter.
Soll teurer werden?
Ja, da warte ich.
Klar.
Okay, Leute.
Wir sehen uns eventuell morgen.
Schauen wir mal.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.